it was called the peace wall but a
ceasefire took
three decades to achieve now 23 years
after the good friday peace agreement
was signed
it fails to live up to its name again
descent on the streets
is reborn
for more than a week pro-british
loyalists have been attacking police
some of the worst violence has been near
the peace wall in belfast that separates
loyalists on one side from republicans
on the other
billy hutchinson is a former loyalist
paramilitary who served
15 years in jail for murdering two
catholics in 1974.
he points to a mural of loyalty to the
british monarchy
and talks of a lull in violence during
the period of mourning
for prince philip hutchinson is now the
leader of a political party that doesn't
advocate violence
but he won't condemn what's happening i
want these young people to feel
that they can come back from where
they've went they went across a lane
and that lane they need to be able to
step back condemnation will prevent that
it will alienate them more and you know
i think
nobody has used this term yet but i'm
going to use it as far as i know
i don't want people to be radicalized
the brexit trade deal had a late switch
of plan to put a border across the irish
sea
that separates great britain from
northern ireland there's a customs post
on this side among the vexed issues has
been
chaos on imports coming in which are all
subject to european union regulations
put simply even the more moderate
loyalists feel they've been betrayed and
alienated by brexit
but over the peace wall the republican
leadership feel
that the good friday agreement may have
been damaged
but it's secure and will stay that way
shin fein says all sides need to play a
part of the political process
the scenes we're witnessing on our
streets are very disappointing
and dangerous but i don't think we
should uh
suggest that the grief radio agreement
is under threat for what's happening at
this time
it has to be nurtured it has to be
looked after all the players
have to ensure that they play their part
in developing that pace
another major issue is a republican
funeral where shin fein leaders fail to
observe covet regulations
the unionist first minister of northern
ireland is calling for the resignation
of the chief constable
for not making any prosecutions the
violence involves a small minority
many of them teenagers signposts call
for a suspension of protests until
after the period of mourning for prince
philip
even if those calls are heeded scenes
like this
could return soon and for now it seems
there's no solution andrew simmons al
jazeera belfast